many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism is stoicism a
religion this is an entirely
understandable question and one that I
think is is great to grapple with in the
present time given that we don't have
some sort of entirely agreed-upon
definition of religion and the answer is
that for some people in the present yes
stoicism is for them a religion but in
general no stoicism is not a religion
it's always helpful when considering
anything having to do with stoicism to
look at what the classic representatives
of that school actually had to say now
you can certainly assert that the Stoics
themselves were religious and had some
religious conceptions and much of that
was taking the traditional Greek Roman
religion the spread throughout the
Mediterranean and reinterpreting it in
such a way that it would make sense in
relation to the philosophy they were not
the only people to be doing that by the
way the Platonic school the Aristotelian
school the epicurean school all of these
philosophical schools are reinterpreting
a already their religious framework so
the Stoics do have religious conceptions
but they they didn't have something like
their own religion and as a matter of
fact they would be willing to use the
already existing institutions and
rituals of the religion so for example
you know thinking about temples thinking
about festivals all of that panoply of
religious piety was stuff that could be
adopted for stoicism what we can say
about the Stoics reinterpretation of
traditional
is that it's very rationalistic very
much oriented towards practice the
Stoics did believe that there is a logos
with a capital L rationality pervading
the universe they were perfectly happy
calling this Zeus or God but they
dissociated from the traditional
conception of Zeus as this lightning you
know bolt throwing guy who sleeps around
with a whole bunch of different women
cheating on his wife siring demigods all
over the place getting wrapped up in
arguments between the gods that the
stoic said that's all just fables
when it came to other matters of
religious practice for example Oracle's
we see that the Stoics did think that
there was something to the practice of
divination but that we really shouldn't
make any recourse to it unless you know
it's something that really requires
divine input and in most cases we can
answer the question ourselves and so we
shouldn't really concern ourselves with
divination or what the priests might be
saying so you can say that that stoicism
again was religious and it did in fact
interface with the traditional religion
but it was not a religion in ancient
times how then might stoicism be viewed
as a religion by some modern Stoics well
we don't have an agreed-upon definition
of religion whether we're talking about
in philosophy of religion religious
studies or even more generally anybody
who tries to sell you the notion that
there's one single definition of
religion is peddling snake oil to you so
we have a very broad conception of
religion and people can you know select
certain traits and and call things
religions which may not be acceptable as
such to to other people and some people
have in fact in the present taken
stoicism and used it as something like a
faith very often they're coming out of
other room
this context and seeking for something
some people prefer the term spirituality
rather than religion and that's a bit
broader that can also apply to stoicism
and then there's many many people in the
present who say listen stoicism is a
philosophy or it's a life approach it
has nothing to do with with religion in
the traditional sense
so let's disentangle it and you might
ask well which of these views are the
right view they're all perfectly
legitimate within the present stoicism
you might say as a certain compatibility
to be taken to be a religion this is
when you see people engaging in
particular rituals and and getting
together in communities whether
face-to-face or virtual and getting
tattoos of the stoic flame on on parts
of their body
other people are perfectly content to
say listen it's got nothing to do with
religion so if you had to answer the
question is stoicism and religion you
can say yes it is for some people but
there's no church there's no hierarchy
there's no authoritative body some
people have put together what they call
I think rather facetiously a stoic Bible
but there's really no such thing and the
entire attitude I would say involved in
much of modern stoicism is not quite the
same as what we see in religious
communities so the answer is really
stoicism is not a religion but people
can make it into one if they wish to if
you found this answer helpful for you
then please share it with others who
might benefit from it this work is
entirely supported by crowdfunding on my
patreon site so if you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler